I hope he can guess it but if he doesn't
I won't dump him it might throw a wrench
in that whole one-year thing so we'll
see her hands a little smaller and so
feels a little different so we'll have
to see I'm sorry to the person the other
side this is queer
I'm like trying to test out our knuckles
like that soft knuckles or is that
somebody else's but then again I don't
even know it's a few as knuckles feel
like so how do you know I'm trying that
there's a little bit of gamemanship
going on here I think that part of you
guys might've been alas put Sophia first
trick out Tyler oh this is tricky now
now this hand is a little bit bigger and
Sophia's got pretty big hands so while
this is impossible
I'm in pretty intense thought right now
but this feels like a hand that I know
it's like the warmth a little bit and
like I'm adding in some descriptors
which can only hurt me if I'm wrong okay
this fan fuels like a hand I've been
holding okay I this is Sophia's hand I
think Sophia's hand is number three and
I'm really hoping that it is because I'm
pretty nervous right now no who is that
it's two then oh my god no I I thought I
would have known
oh I don't is he she's mad are you
serious I would have been so good at
this no it was not that easy I couldn't
really tell he did horribly why did you
think that the first hand was not my
hand we don't walk this far apart is
really what it is like and so we usually
walk right next to each other and so
we're further apart it just felt
different like the angle is different no
it's fine I'm not mad I'm just
disappointed
listen I've held one hand for a year and
maybe of other people get them then
they're better holding hands than us I
think that we're pretty awesome being
boyfriend/girlfriend right there you go